[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اكبر ظاهره علميه تحدث عندنا في الجزيره
العربيه
جريان وادي الرمه ولهذا يسمى بشيخ الاوديه
علاوه على ذلك انه من معشوقنا لقد سمعنا
باوصاف له كملت فسرنا ما سمعنا واحيانا من
قبل رؤيته منا محبته والاذن تعشق قبل
العين
احيانا فهو معشوقنا وعلاقتنا مع وادي
الرمه علاقه حياتيه وعلاقه نفسيه العلاقه
الحياتيه يعمل على رفع مياه الابار
الجوفيه
ويقلل ملوحه هذه الابار علاوه على ذلك انه
يجدد خصوبه الارض وعلاقه نفسيه العلاقه
النفسيه تتلخص في اننا سعداء عندما نشاهد
هذا الوادي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وانا امثل عشق المنطقه لهذا الوادي فانا
انام واكل واشرب بجانبي هذا الوادي كانت
مسائله الركباني تخبرنا عن جابر بن حيان
افضل الخبر ثم التقينا فوالله ما سمعت
اذني باحسن مما رات
بصل
[موسيقى]